is the Texas Roadhouse roll they're
sweet buttery and delicious and I was
determined to make a copycat version on
my own so I went to the restaurant and
did some investigating how many rolls a
day would you say that you serve
anywhere from five to ten thousand is
there any secret ingredient you can tell
us mainly just the sugar is something we
don't put too much but just a perfect
amount I've had some good Insider tips
and after a complete role analysis I
went home to recreate the Beloved
Roadhouse rolls now one crucial part of
this recipe is making sure you have a
really good quality yeast that isn't
expired so the bread Rises nicely in the
oven Texas Roadhouse is also known for
their famous honey cinnamon butter which
I also perfectly recreated my version
came out absolutely spot on extremely
fluffy and so delicious you gotta try it